>> Tucker: IT'S INTERESTING TO
IT FIND OUT WHAT FAMOUS PEOPLE
ARE LIKE.
A LOT OF PROMINENT PEOPLE ARE
NOT GREAT.
THEY ARE NOT LOYAL TO THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR THEM.
LOYALTY IS A PREREQUISITE FOR AN
HONORABLE LIFE.
AND DANA WHITE DEMONSTRATED THAT
AND WAS LOYAL TO HIS FRIENDS
EVEN HIS FRIENDS WERE THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD.
HE AND DONALD TRUMP HAVE BEEN
FRIENDS FOR YEARS.
HE SPOKE WHEN DONALD TRUMP RAN
FOR PRESIDENT.
HE IS NOT AFRAID.
HE DO NOT WORK FOR THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
HE IS IN A VIOLENT SPORT.
HE TALKED ABOUT HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH TRUMP.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
TRUMP DESCRIBED YOU AS THE ONLY
ESSENTIAL PERSON IN ALL AMERICAN
SPORTS.
YOU COULD TAKE KEY PEOPLE OUT OF
ANY SPORT AND THE SPORT WOULD
CONTINUE.
IF DANA WHITE LEFT UFC, THERE
COULD NOT BE UFC.
YOU ARE THE SAME AGE AS I AM.
53.
HOW LONG WILL YOU DO THIS?
>> I LOVE HIM AND APPRECIATE
THAT.
HOPEFULLY I BUILT A BUSINESS
OVER THE LAST 22 YEARS, NO
MATTER WHO COMES AND GOES, TELL
LAST AND CONTINUE TO GROW.
I KNOW FOR A FACT THAT WHEN I DO
LEAVE, THE RIGHT PERSON NEEDS TO
BE IN PLACE TO TAKE OVER.
THERE IS A FORMULA TO THIS
BUSINESS.
MANY PEOPLE ARE TRYING IT RIGHT
NOW AND HAVE NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
I KNOW WHY.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHY.
WHEN I WATCH THEM RUNNING THEIR
BUSINESSES, I JUST SHAKE MY HEAD
AND GO, YEAH, YEAH.
WHEN I DO DECIDE TO LEAVE WHICH
WON'T BE SOON BECAUSE I STILL
LOVE WHAT I AM DOING.
I AM STILL AS PASSIONATE ABOUT
IT AS DAY 1, I WILL HAVE THE
RIGHT PEOPLE IN PLACE.
I HAVE BUILT A PHENOMENAL TEAM
HERE.
NO ONE GUY JUST DOES ANYTHING.
YOU NEED A GREAT TEAM TO
SURROUND YOURSELF WITH.
I HAVE DONE THAT.
THERE IS NO WAY I WOULD LET ANY
OF THESE PEOPLE LEAVE WHEN COVID
HIT.
>> Tucker: I DIDN'T REALIZE YOU
WERE A LEGIT FRIEND OF TRUMP
BECAUSE OF WORK.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN SUCH
A GOOD FRIEND TO ME SINCE THE
DAY I MET HIM.
THIS COMPANY HAD SUCH A BAG
STIGMA ATTACHED TO IT, VENUES
DIDN'T WANT US.
DONALD TRUMP SAW THIS COULD BE
BIG.
PLUS, HE LOVES SPORTS.
HE OFFERED US TO COME AND DO THE
EVENT AT THE TRUMP TAJ MAHAL IN
ATLANTIC CITY.
HE SHOWED UP FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND STAYED FOR THE LAST FIGHT.
TRUMP UP HERE AND WHARFING DOWN
HERE.
-- UFC DOWN HERE.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED, THE
FIRST GUY TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS
WAS DONALD TRUMP.
WE WERE ON THE COVER OF THE "NEW
YORK TIMES," HE SAID I KNEW YOU
WOULD DO IT, DANA AND SENT ME
THE PAPER.
SENT ME A PEN TO CONGRATULATE
ME.
ALWAYS SENDING SOMETHING.
A GUY WHO WAS HAPPY FOR YOUR
SUCCESS.
>> Tucker: NOT A TON OF THOSE?
>> NO, THEN CAME THE DAY HE WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
HE CALLED ME AND SAID YOU, "YOU
DON'T WANT TO DO THIS, I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND AND THERE
ARE NO HARD FEELINGS.
BUT I WOULD BE HONORED IF YOU
WOULD SPEAK FOR ME AT THE
NATIONAL REPUBLICAN CONVENTION."
I SAID I WILL BE THERE.
>> HE RECOGNIZED THE POTENTIAL
OF THE UFC AND ENCOURAGED US TO
START THE BUSINESS.
HE GOT IN THE TRENCHES WITH US
AND MADE A DEAL THAT WORKED FOR
EVERYONE.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A GREAT GUY
TO ME AND A GOOD FRIEND TO ME.
I SPOKE THAT DAY.
AFTER THAT DAY, OUR FRIENDSHIP
WENT TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN SO GOOD TO ME.
IT'S UNEXPLAINABLE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FASCINATING.
A WINDOW INTO SOMETHING WE DON'T
GET TO SEE.
DID YOU TAKE A LOT OF ABUSE FOR
THAT OR DID PEOPLE ACCEPT THIS
IS A REAL FRIENDSHIP?
>> YEAH -- I AM IN THE ABUSE
BUSINESS.
WE TAKE ABUSE EVERY DAY.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO ME
WHAT THE ABUSE ON THE TRUMP SIDE
WOULD BE.
I GET IT.
THIS IS WHAT IS SAD.
OBVIOUSLY I DIDN'T VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE IS MY PRESIDENT.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND I AM AN
AMERICAN.
I DON'T DISLIKE OR HATE ANYBODY
WHO VOTED FOR BIDEN.
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE THE TYPE
OF PERSON THAT WOULD HATE
SOMEBODY BECAUSE OF WHO THEY
VOTED FOR SHOWS ME WHO YOU ARE.
I DON'T WANT TO KNOW YOU ANYWAY.
YOU ARE NOT MY KIND OF PERSON.
I DON'T WANT TO BE FRIENDS WITH
YOU EITHER.
THE FEELING IS MUTUAL.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF WHO YOU
VOTED FOR.
IT'S BECAUSE OF HOW YOU CARRY
YOURSELF.
WHO YOU VOTE FOR OR WHAT YOU DO
WITH YOUR LIFE MEANS NOTHING TO
ME.
THAT'S YOUR PERSONAL CHOICE.
AMERICA IS A FREE COUNTRY.